[Music]
about two years ago i started at
riskafide an e-commerce fraud prevention
company based in tel aviv israel
previously i'd worked with ecological
and environmental sciences data
i'd worked with a lot of different kinds
of files shape files
xml csvs of course
sometimes thousands at a time but i
haven't really gotten the chance to work
so much with databases
so i was really excited to enter a world
where there were millions of orders
coming in each day
there were teams dedicated to setting up
etls
to process that incoming data and get it
neat and tidy into databases for me
and all i had to do is query that data
into r and start playing
and i was excited because you know i had
r
under my belt and r was this super
multi-tool
but seemed to be able to do almost
anything i used it to create
slides and websites and used it for
querying apis and even building apis
you know it did a lot for what was you
know supposedly just this
statistical tool sql on the other hand
was a little bit more like
a screwdriver it's a perfectly
fine tool but it seems to be only really
good at one thing
which is to query databases
and so going to riskified um in my mind
was a little bit of this feeling of
why bother to learn sql if i can just
use r for everything
one reason i was fairly confident is
because
i knew about this package called dbplier
which is an extension of d
plier that runs on databases so
instead of running something on a data
frame in your r
session you're actually running it on a
table in a database but it feels like
it's just a data frame and what it's
doing is it's taking your tidy verse
code
translating it into sql sending it off
to the database
bringing it back and then giving you
this you know table output like you're
used to
as if everything all happened locally
and so um if if we look at how this
works let's let's just take a simple our
example where i have
now an empty cars table in his database
i take some variable miles per gallon
round it create this new variable
and then i select two other variables uh
this
rounded miles per gallon and then
horsepower
if i look at the translation it also
looks fairly good
it looks somewhat similar to the r code
i'm rounding it i get the horsepower
from empty cars the table
if i were to have written this out by
hand i
i probably wouldn't write in the back
text but otherwise it looks almost the
same
and sometimes using db ply really saves
you a lot of
kind of tedious work for example if i
want all columns
except for horsepower i can use this you
know simple expression
in d plier and then it generates the sql
code where i like i literally have to
write out
every single column except for
horsepower
if i want to now take the maximum across
all of the different
columns i can also do it very easily in
dbplier it's just one line of code
and then it's able to generate this
really long and very repetitive query
for me it's not a hard query to write
but
you know it does take some effort and it
is very repetitive
but the thing is over time you also
realize
um that you know what you're used to
doing in just regular dpr
isn't always going to work when you're
connected to a database
for example if i now want to look at the
number of
n a's or nulls across every single
column
i can you know use this one liner in r
if i try to do the same thing on a table
we'll say
no such column dot x
it's angry at me because i'm trying to
use an anonymous function
and it doesn't know how to translate the
anonymous function
so what i have to do is i have to fix
this this set of commands i have to
break it up
into the individual steps which is is in
a first and then the sum
and now i'll work
well now we'll work for some databases
and and this is where where it kind of
becomes
complicated a little bit on the one hand
dbplier
saves you kind of the mental load of
learning sql this whole new language
but on the other hand you still have to
realize that you're working with
databases
it does a lot of the translations to
dialects for you
but you have to know what is specific to
your database in some
databases for example is na becomes a
boolean
in other databases isn't a becomes an
integer
and depending on what you're using you
might have to convert it into an integer
in order to sum it up
because it can't sum up booleans and so
you have to
make sure to still juggle that
information in your mind
as you're using deep pliers so it's you
are using something you're used to
but you can't use exactly in the way
that
you normally would and so over time
i did really start to appreciate sql the
screwdriver
um because even they have their moments
and you know sometimes it is easier to
just
switch over to a different language
rather than to try to juggle
how regular d plier is different from
like db
prior deep um code um on
this specific database
um and so for example if i take what i
had from before i switch out the ending
and now
i have a group by and summarize instead
if i were to write this out by hand it's
also a fairly simple sql query
the ordering is a little bit different
but otherwise it has all the same
components
if i now take the machine translation of
this
um it looks a little bit scary at first
it's going to run just fine it's just as
sufficient
it's not going to have any problems you
can see that it's not as readable
it's harder to distinguish what here is
really important
what is just kind of extra
code that that is used to generate this
uh
to automatically generate this query
and so at some point once you have to
you know hand sql code off to someone
else
or if you need to really optimize for
speed and you need to kind of input some
of these
little database tricks um that you know
about
you have to dig into the sequel there's
just no way around it
and for me it's kind of like using
google translate um i live in israel
i did not grow up speaking hebrew you
know i
learned the alphabet just a few years
ago
and i can't get around with just google
translate
i can survive but you also really
quickly realize
that it's it doesn't
you you can't express yourself exactly
in the way
that you want to you lose out on a lot
of the nuances of the language
and sometimes you even have to alter the
way you
input your english sentence in order for
the translation to come out okay on the
other side
speaking of language that's that's one
other
really amazing thing about sql it's kind
of this lingua franca
um along among at least like the
technical folks
in a company of course the data base
administrators are familiar with it but
also business analysts data scientists
software developers everyone has at
least that core level of
sql so if you need to communicate some
actions you want to do
to data this is a really good way to
communicate that
through code
and so with time i realized really that
r and sql
belong in the same toolkit you can
survive on just one or the other
but over time it's really nice to be
able to use both
very well especially if you're in this
intersection of using r
and databases
the nice thing is if you know one it's
fairly easy to become bilingual
if you look at just the main verbs for
example in each of the
the two languages you see there's a lot
of overlap
um select a select group bias group by
um
there are some things you have to learn
you have to realize filters now where or
having
in sql uh range is ordered by and so on
and so forth so there is a little bit of
translation you have to do
but it's not too big of a leap
and the other thing is if you're used to
r then you
you know that you kind of write things
out in the order that they happen
so let's say i have a table i filter by
some condition
okay now i group by some column and get
a summarized aggregate column
and then i filter by that column for
example and then i can arrange
by something if i were to write this out
in sql
i would have to um i would start with
yeah the table
the condition group by now the select or
the summarize
jumps all the way up to the top um
having is at the bottom again order by
is also at the bottom
and so you have to kind of remember that
the ordering is a little bit different
you don't necessarily
write things in the order that you would
do them um
but other than that but it's something
that you you get used to
fairly quickly um and if you're like me
and
and you spend a lot of time in our
studio the nice thing is there are a lot
of sql things
you can do from within that familiar
environment of our
and especially with the newer versions
of the ide
for example if you open up a sql file
you have your nice
you know colors syntax highlighting so
you can see what the verbs are what the
you know the table names are
what i didn't realize for the longest
time is there's this line at the top
that says you know exclamation mark
preview with some
stuff after that this is where you can
actually set a connection
so if you set a connection to the
database you can get the sql preview
pane
where you can preview that sql query
within rstudio
this took me a while to figure out but
it's a really nice feature
our markdown is this kind of magical
document where you can mix
all kinds of different languages and r
and sql is no exception
you'll start probably with some kind of
animal header like usual
you might have an r setup chunk where
you have packages
the database connection maybe you'll set
up a table like i did here
and then you can have your sql query and
if you have this inline
mode uh enabled you can actually see
those
previews within our markdown and work
with both r
and sql interactively within this one
document
and finally you can navigate through
your database
from within r you can see what databases
you have
schemas tables columns within tables
all within that rstudio interface
and so i've talked a lot about like all
these cool things about
r and sql together but what does that
look like in real life
i wish i i knew more about what people
are doing in the wider world
out in the wild so to speak um but i can
only really speak to
my experience and experience of my
colleagues at riskified on a regular day
i'm often switching between sql id and
art studio
i just i did just talk about all these
sql things you can do with rstudio but
some
are still not quite that mature um and
so i really like using the sql ide
for all of the extra auto formatting
highlighting
code and field suggestions so i don't
have to remember those long table names
just from memory one other thing is that
it's really easy to stop bad queries
um in a dedicated ide sometimes in our
studio it gets stuck and i
like press on that red button for ages
and in the end i have to just
force quit my rstudio and just
start over
on the rstudio side there are a lot of
nice r features obviously
visualizations reporting being able to
mix languages in the same document as we
mentioned earlier
but i think maybe most importantly you
have this ability to organize your
analysis project
and on top of that have version control
that means you have your
you know you have your sql files your
data files your r file maybe our
markdown files
all together in one space it's a project
that you can now easily give to someone
else and have them work on it and have
everything work
and on top of that everything is version
controlled so you can
connect directly to github and have it
all sit there as well
and so speaking of project structure
if you were to you know take a walk
through the github repositories at
riskified
you would often encounter some kind of
folder structure like this
where you have sql files where you're
reading in relevant data doing some
initial data processing
getting that initial sample population
ready for analysis
and then you have your r files where you
do that all the complex steps
the stats visualizations etc sometimes
you're bringing
extra information from the database in
between with smaller queries
and then finally you have this darn
report where you share your results and
conclusions with stakeholders and this
is where
both of those pieces really come
together into this
one final product and because we're
using r and sql so much
within riskify we actually have a
dedicated
package to handle those database
connections and also
just add little helpers that help us
with our day-to-day flow
for example we keep all our
configurations within this package
you know anything that's not too
sensitive like a host name
port etc we just stick into the package
if we need to update it we just
update it in that one place and as long
as people reinstall the package
it gets updated across all the computers
the other thing is that we basically
just use one database
at least among the analytical teams and
so unless you spec
explicitly provide a database connection
we assume
we know what what you want and so that's
built into our our very own get query
function
there was one point recently where we
actually had to
migrate from one database to another it
was
a bit of a slog but one thing that did
help smooth it over a little bit
was this option we added to switch
between the old database or the new
database
you just had to do it once at the
beginning of your r session
and it would last for all of your get
query so you didn't have to go in and
now to start changing your code
to specify the database connection for
every single query in your code
one small thing that we do a lot also is
caching query results
we the first time you ask the database
directly
the second time it will store the result
it will have stored the result
in some temporary file it's cached ready
for reading and
and unless you force it to connect to
the database again
you have a much quicker response second
time around
and that saves on a lot of time as
you're iterating through your analysis
and finally we also have other little
helpers like access to pipelines for
bringing large amounts of data
from r to the database or the other way
around
sometimes insert statements just don't
cut it
and you need for us what is easier is to
dump the data into some cloud storage
and then bring it directly into the
database or going the other way around
and so to conclude r and sql they both
have
their strengths r is great for
summarization of cost columns especially
selecting specific columns translations
to multiple dialects
if you're working with several databases
sql on the other hand
is great for um it like is really needed
when you need to optimize for speed or
readability because you're handing it
off
to another team to review that code
and you know there's there's still a lot
to learn i'm sure i'm
i'm still on this journey of learning
how to use rnsql
well together um but i would love to
also hear from you
is your story similar different from
mine
my contact details are here and thank
you so much for listening today